foreign
[Music]
to give the keys back they really don't
like giving it back my biggest fear is
the civil liberties implication of of
what will come
to this
down the road when I sit down the road I
mean a year two years from now there is
a risk of very serious inflation and I
think we will look back on this if we
ever have a chance to do so with it with
an impartial inquiry and say how on
Earth did we go mad to this extent it
simply wasn't Justified and I think
there will be when this is examined a
fair number of excess deaths this is
political belief and ideology over
rational scientific argument
I still don't think people understand
what's about to happen
I really don't think they understand
that we leave ourselves vulnerable at
some point in a not too distant future
to blackouts it's about to blow up this
year it's about a blower
[Music]
hey Francis do you like Scottish
Wildlife yeah I love Glasgow on a Friday
night no you idiot I mean Scottish Birds
Oh you mean Morag nah we're not seeing
each other anymore
if you do love Scottish national
woodlands and the wildlife then you have
to check out established titles they're
selling one square foot of dedicated
land with a unique plot number on a
private estate in edelston in Scotland
and an official certificate with a Crest
established titles is a fun and novel
way to preserve the natural Woodlands of
Scotland whilst helping Global
reforestation efforts it's a Project
based on a historic Scottish custom
where landowners are referred to as
leads the Scottish call them leads
because they can't spell Lords it's the
whiskey I'm gonna ignore that they plan
a treat with every order and work with
global Charities one tree planted and
trees for the future to support Global
reforestation efforts you could
officially include the title Lord or
lady on your credit card plane tickets
dating profiles Etc it makes a great
last minute gift unless you're a
socialist and you want the aristocracy
abolished established titles is actually
one a massive early Black Friday sale
right now plus if you use a code
trigonometry you get an additional 10
off go to established titles.com
trigonometry to get your gifts now go to
established titles.com trigonometry and
get 10 off this wonderful gift
[Music]
hello Stavros this is Lord Foster of
Croydon mate yes what I want Kebab salt
and pepper extra chili sauce salt and
vinegar on the chips what do you mean
you're shot I'm a lord you should always
be open for me
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People we have a collection of guests
for you today but before that we should
explain why we're sitting in front of a
black curtain again and the reason is
our new studio is being built literally
as we speak so this is what we're doing
with it at the moment but rest assured
it will be back very very shortly and as
those of you who are on locals know it's
going to be absolutely awesome we've
posted a bunch of back stage footage of
it so you can see what is going on but
in the meantime one of the things we've
always focused on the show is attempting
to give you information about some of
the economic trends that are coming and
some of the other things that are going
on in the world that are likely to
happen in the future so what we've done
for you today is we've collected a bunch
of times when our former guests have
predicted what was about to happen in a
way that we think was is going to be
very useful to you so enjoy
our brilliant and returning guest this
week is Mike Driver you may remember we
did an interview with him some time ago
he's a Serial entrepreneur all-around
good guy and someone who has a lot of
very counter-intuitive ideas so Mike
Driver welcome back to trigonometry
I'm delighted to be back thanks for
having me again
Mike uh what is it that we're not seeing
what is it that we're not talking about
what do you with a kind of totally
different mindset to most people that I
know what what is out of our field of
vision that's coming
well I think one of the consequences I
mean I think people are talking about
this but but my my biggest fear and it's
not my biggest fear for for the economy
or the country maybe the biggest fear of
the country is the civil liberties
implication of of what will come after
this
um
a rushing a vaccine through that's a
frightening Prospect
um in many ways vaccine vaccinating many
young people who who don't necessarily
need a vaccine is is concerning
um thinking about how you're going to be
monitored how you're going to be tagged
how how uh your movements are going to
be big brothered
um I think all of these things
I think is it Jeremy Bentham and the
concept of the people's behavior changed
the panopticon if they're watched all
the time their behavior changes and I
think that's quite Dynamic amongst
populations as well I think for some
people for many people and it kind of
goes back to the the Huxley and the
Brave New World view of where we are is
they is they may Embrace that they may
Embrace that um that that that sort of
monitoring that herding to use a the
phrase in a different way well there's
many many other people and other people
that affect change who are going to find
that intolerable so it took breaking the
law to change many of the things that we
now take for granted be it the
suffragettes or
homosexuality or many of those things
um it took people who who who who are
prepared to step outside for boundaries
and similarly the way the way most
entrepreneurial people think is is is to
be is to be outside of the mainstream
and I think if we limit that and I think
that is that is perhaps the thing that
worries me most is we will limit the
ability of those people who affect
change to do so and so where where will
that where will that leave us in a very
homogeneous world it's not a world I
particularly want to live in right well
let me push back on that a little bit
because as you know I you know if there
was anyone who was concerned about the
erosion of our civil liberties
restrictions of free speech that to me
I've been pretty outspoken about this
for a long time but I've got to be
honest with you I don't I look around I
mean yes in Australia they're talking
about some kind of app to track your
immunity status and and that would be a
hill that I'm I'm prepared to die on I'm
not signing up to any [ __ ] app that
tracks me around the country no way but
if you can't travel would you
right that but this is yeah I mean yeah
it's exactly this is exactly my point if
someone said to you uh your passport is
dependent on you carrying your contact
tracing app yeah then then most of us
would and it's it erodes doesn't it so
it starts with a contract
tracing app where does it go after that
right but my broader point I mean I take
your point on that and that is a a step
way too far in my opinion but more
broadly speaking I do see the the you
know a lot of the people we've had on
the show who we like and respect kind of
in my opinion going way off the deep end
on this stuff and talking about how
we're all under house arrest and all
this kind which I I think is a massive
exaggeration I think a temporary and
necessary lockdown is not the same as
house arrest I personally don't feel
like Western governments have been
overly restrictive about this in in
proportion to the threat that we're
facing you know it is a war like time
you accept a little bit more imposition
on your freedoms during that time
provided that time limited provided
their specific provided we can go back
to you know having a free Society
afterwards are you do you see signs that
that's not going to happen is what what
what's the reason for your concern
I I never trust people in power to give
the keys back
um once once once once they get was
similar to the the
um mmt conversation that we had earlier
once you give
um people in power power
uh and consider that their their reasons
for living all the odd to obtain power
they really don't like giving it back
um so I I do I well I might not be at
the
but the further end of the spectrum of
the previous guests you've had
I uh we we as a country as a as a
species have fought
and lost millions of lives to maintain
uh freedoms and I don't think that
should be lost
um there are consequences there's
serious consequences to giving up
um giving up the things that that enable
us to change and I think that's that
that's what scares me most is
when you have a contact tracing app that
you need to have
do you have you've given
um
the political order a lever in with
which to dictate or which to demand your
your obedience and anything that does
that anything that does that more I
think that's that would be very very
worrying and you say you die on a hill
for it but the reality is most people
won't I know when most people won't
you'll be you'll be in the minority and
then
your wife will want to take a nice
holiday somewhere and and your kids will
be saying dad's an idiot what difference
does it make and and compliance will
become the norm and that that worries me
and Fascinating People we have for you
today two brilliant returning guests to
trigonometry here they are Jim Rickards
and paper malgram to expert economists
people who understand Finance people who
understand uh what is going to happen
Tech as well as all of those things that
we're going to get into Jim people
welcome back thank you thank you is
there going to be hell to pay for for
the money that we are now using to save
people's jobs and protect businesses no
there's there's no chance of inflation
um in fact the the real partial concern
is and will be deflation now down the
road uh I'm not when I say down the road
I mean a year two years from now there
is a risk of
um very serious inflation bordering and
hyperinflation but not now and not for
at least a year and here's why inflation
has nothing to do with money supply this
is sort of a
um I've called a myth or a
misunderstanding that's been propagated
by
everyone from the Neo keynesians to the
monitors to the austrians uh you know
increase the money supply too much money
chasing too few goods
um inflation is right around the corner
it's not true money supply has nothing
to do with inflation
um what does Drive inflation is uh
psychology
um it which shows up in the form of
velocity so let's say I have a let's say
I'm feeling good I go out to dinner you
know I tip the waiter
um he takes a taxi home and tips the
taxi driver and the taxi driver takes a
tip and puts gas in her taxi uh well
that in that example my dollar has
velocity of three there was a tip a taxi
tip and gasoline so velocity of three
instead imagine I stay home and watch
television uh my money has velocity of
zero right and I remind people that five
trillion dollars times zero is zero if
you don't have velocity you don't have
an economy period so the task is and a
pivot touched on this she's exactly
right the task is to change the
psychology change expectations uh you
can print all the money you want the FED
can stick the landing on base money m
zero I'm I'm you know one M2 is a a
different matter but m0 they can print
that to like two decimal places not a
problem but they can't get people to
lend it they can't get people to spend
it they can't get get people to to just
save in other words what are people
doing with the money they are they're
either going to uh well if you if you
have a high marginal propensity to
consume meaning you're you know you're
living paycheck to paycheck and you need
to pay the rent yes you'll pay the rent
fair enough but um for many people they
will uh save it uh for the reason Pippa
mentioned which is they're worried about
how long is this going to last you know
even if you're not laid off if your
neighbor was laid off you're probably
worried about your own job so you'll
save it on a precautionary basis or
you'll pay off you know credit card pay
down a lot of loan which is economically
the same thing it's just another form of
saving so that's what people are going
to do with the money there you won't see
the velocity from it people before
Francis jumps in let me ask you this
because you're a former advisor to two
U.S presidents if you're sitting in the
Oval Office right now and you're looking
at the fact and this I come back to the
issue of globalization here you're
looking at the fact that 97 of your
antibiotics are made in China you know a
huge quantity and percentage of us
essential supplies are made in China a
lot of particularly right leaning
commentators have been banging away at
this point you know we've become reliant
on China for essential supplies in a
world where you know I mean we don't
know exactly what's happened with this
virus but there's some evidence to
suggest that you know it's not without
China's
at best incompetence that this has
spread the way that it has right so if
you can't trust them and you know when
when the the proverbial hits the fan
countries tend to lock down and go I
need this and you're not having that
yeah are we
I know as a president of the United
States or the prime minister of Britain
are you going to go we need to onshore
not just manufacturing of widgets and
iPhones we need to onshore manufacturing
and medical supplies syringes cerventor
everything yes uh and it's not only
because you know China didn't handle it
well I think probably most countries
wouldn't have handled it well I'm not
sure that the British did so much better
and they were loaded with a lot more
information and they were still slow but
the main thing is what you're talking
about is a trade-off between efficiency
and resilience and for many years we
have gone after efficiency and cheaper
prices ever cheaper prices that that was
our driver now we're faced with this
reality that resilience is is interfered
with by that and I'll come I'd like to
use the example in Formula One racing
that it's a constant race between
resilience and efficiency and what
you're doing is you rip that car apart
every single day and you try to shave
one gram of weight off of the thing so
that you improve its chances of winning
but that one gram may be the thing that
breaks the piece you're working on so
it's either correct or catastrophe right
you're on the borderline all the time
well this is where we are with the
economy we chose efficiency efficiency
efficiency and we shaved off that extra
gram of cost by Outsourcing it to China
and now we see a break and therefore now
we're gonna have an emphasis on
resilience now what does that mean that
means inflation that means higher prices
it means you say I'm willing to pay more
for a British sourced product or an
American sourced product so that I'm
sure to get it then I care about its
reduced cost and that's another Channel
through which higher prices begin to
worm their way forward now this this in
the light of the current president let's
just keep in mind who the current
president is the current president
United States is a property guy property
guys make all their money on inflation
they love inflation
and so what is his inclination going to
be he's always going to be we should
just have more debt and the way you deal
with the debt is you basically inflate
and that's okay and by the way
inflations they do tend to make asset
markets go up which means stock markets
and I would argue we've had that
inflation has shown up in recent years
as higher asset prices and everybody
loved that part about it and they
ignored the fact that a consumer had to
go from one percent inflation at the
time of the financial crisis to say two
and a half at the time of the covid
crisis and that just sounds like nothing
but to Jim's Point that's a ton of
inflation that lets you completely erode
uh the debt you owe the world and the
U.S is particularly privileged in that
because everybody's still willing to buy
dollars from the states even though we
behave this way and by the way we have
behaved this way throughout history
because how do we pay for the American
Revolution on inflation how do we pay
for the Civil War a much bigger
inflation how do we pay for Vietnam
another inflation and how are we going
to pay for this mess on inflation and so
that's why I said in the opening I think
that we're heading into inflation so
then the question becomes what's the
speed and magnitude of that thing and
and I agree with Jim usually great
inflations are preceded by a puff of
deflation and whether that lasts a year
18 months two years I don't know but we
have seemingly set the stage for prices
to begin creeping up and for people to
say again it's a psychological
phenomenon to say you know like in my
world I have people companies who are
saying you know the Chinese drones may
be cheaper but I'd rather buy British or
the Chinese drones uh you know maybe I
can buy them the supply chains there but
I'd rather work with someone who's
closer and speaks English and can work
with me to produce what I really require
for my business that means they're
telling me they're willing to pay more
for this and I think they'll pay more
for these things now that they go I need
to be digital and I need to not travel I
need to be more localized not globalized
so in this sense it all comes together
to form a full circle
that what Jim and I have written about
inflation which everybody says is a dead
duck and never coming back to life is
distinctly quacking in the background
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
but this is the show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People and our brilliant returning guest
is Peter Hitchens the author and
journalist Peter welcome back to the
show well so far it's okay
yeah I have to say we've never had a
guest interrupt Us Mid intro but you've
managed so let's get straight into it uh
one of the reasons that we were really
Keen to have you back uh on the show is
that you have done a lot of alternative
coverage shall we say of the lockdown
and the coronavirus situation so for
anyone who has not been following your
writing and opinions on this issue just
give us a brief overview of what is your
opinion of what's happened and the
lockdown measures that have been
implemented okay right from the start I
said that the response to the government
was completely out of proportion to the
size of the minutes I didn't say there
was no disease I didn't say nobody would
die and say it wasn't horrible for a lot
of people if they got it but I said that
as an event it simply didn't justify the
measures being taken either to suppress
Liberty or to suppress the economy I
think that the damage to both human
Liberty and the economy have been huge
and probably permanent and I think we
will look back on this if we ever have a
chance to do so with with an impartial
inquiry and say how on Earth uh did we
go mad to this extent it simply wasn't
Justified
how many people have died or otherwise
suffered or will die otherwise suffer as
a result of these methods the the
healthy old have suffered hugely in
terms of being deprived of normal life
and as a brilliant man Professor Sutra
bhakti of the University of Mainz and
Germany warned at the beginning of this
and I did what I could to publicize this
morning it is precisely those people the
healthy old and active in society who've
suffered very very greatly from this by
being cut off from social contact
and the amount of misery which of course
brings on death that of course is the
effect which I think everybody
acknowledges on the rest of the Health
Service while the Health Service is
concentrating entirely on Kobe all kinds
of other things particularly the
detection and treatment of major cancers
is put to one side and I think there
will be when this is examined a fair
number of excess deaths which have
resulted from this this policy which
have not been covered that so not even
been remotely related to code which are
among people who who would deprived of
treatments and checks they otherwise
would have got because of the panic so
sure
we're all concerned I I completely
concede that my opponents in this
argument are concerned with saving human
life and their motives are good well
actually so am I but I think not really
on my motives group but I think my
assessment and this situation is better
than theirs and I think if my policy is
uh much more closely aligned to what
Sweden has done have been followed a
fewer people uh would have died you
think the health consequences of uh the
way we've reacted are going to run for
years and years
I I you can't tell exactly how bad the
damage is
the enormous load which Mainline canes
negotiated for this country from the
United States at the end of the second
world war when that leaves stopped uh
was was negotiating I think uh July of
1945 and wasn't paid off until December
2006. my entire childhood was spent in a
country which was constantly weighed
down by the paying off of and the paying
of interest on that enormous level our
lives were greater and more pinched and
our public service is worse uh you look
at look at things like Council house
building in the early 50s look at the
low standards of the architecture in the
building the country was poor and it was
poor because it was in debt and and and
but that was a depth honorably
contractors as a result of War this is
occasion it's going to be poor because
of the debt contracted because of the
government mistake
Richardson has no choice it is it is
really a question of how soon he has to
announce the emergency budget the first
I think of many emergency budgets which
you will have to introduce which I will
be one of the few people who will not be
shocked by and the these budgets will be
very serious and people who think that
it can all be loaded on the well-off and
very much mistaken the things vit the
duties and all kinds of things
particularly on travel I wonder how many
people who learn to go back on holiday
are going to feel about how much more
expensive it's going to be
uh quite possibly there's going to be
something called the capital Levy a raid
on the savings or agree that means
amongst other things quite possibly on
the value of houses which people have
bought it's unprecedented in a in a free
country such as this which people will
find particularly since it's levied on
the savings they've made from already
tax money they'll find very oppressive
but the government will probably call it
something like an NHS surcharge it'll be
very hard to resist politically and I
doubt very much whether the labor
opposition will resist it because they
will know their own economists to know
that there is no choice the government
is going to have to improve tax the
other thing that's going to happen is as
a country we're going to be so much in
debt
that the the levels of uh of of of
Interest which we're going to be willing
to pay uh to the Pension funds and the
insurance companies which loans so much
of the money to the government are going
to be fantastically low that means a
raid on the pensions and savings of
millions of people whose old ages will
be under threat that also happens and
the other thing is the world will look
at us and see an economy much weaker
than most and it may be less and less
willing to lend us money on on the terms
which we've been willing to do so and
then one of the results of this and
always certainly be a decline in the
international value of the pattern
Sterling so again that that has many
many affairs from particularly on the
cost of imported goods uh and on our
ability to travel abroad which people
will feel there's going to be a lot of
things going on and it all of them are
going to hurt part of the problem is
that people are living in this kind of
dream time at the moment the beautiful
weather
the following which means people get
paid for not working the usual numbers
of Professionals in the Southeast who
are spared from the daily ground
commuting and so far have continued to
be able to work from home but will come
a moment of Awakening where many of
those people find they don't have any
jobs or if they do they're much worse
pay than they were before and that an
economy base incredibly heavily on
Services particularly shops and
restaurants and bars will have suffered
enormously for months and months during
which people couldn't actually make a
living and they can't and it the a key
feature of Economics is not just the
existence of nothing but the speed in
which it circulates and if your salary
isn't paid or if the rent that your own
isn't paid for a quarter of the year
then the damage it does to your personal
economy into the national economy is
huge and people say it'll be a v-shaped
recession we'll leave out of it well I
hope they're right but I have a strong
feeling that they may be over optimistic
about that as I say this is a dream time
this long long period of sunny weather
during which chattering classes and lays
in their Gardens drinking misted glasses
of waitress shabby uh thinking it's all
going to be great
it isn't
uh they'll be lucky to be able to afford
the Shabbos over in my but my guess it's
going to be really hot it can't be
anything else no one no government's
ever spent this much money in peace time
horrifying prophecy there from Peter
Hitchens the middle classes will have to
go over that shably it's a terrifying
Prospect is it not that they are they
may go home in a way that other warnings
don't
hey KK do you like mattresses of course
in Russia we make mattress out of skins
of dead Bears we wrestle bear for
pleasure and then skin and eat it after
that we say prayer to Glorious leader of
Vladimir Lenin God of hunting what if
the bear kills you that's how you know
you're not Russian only when the man
fights bear do you realize he's from
which country like Venezuela always an
education mate but if you are looking
for mattresses then you have to check
out Emma's sleep Emma sleep create
wonderful beds and mattresses at an
affordable price if you you go on their
website they always have incredible
discounts and by using our link www dot
Emma hyphen mattress dot Co dot UK slash
trigger you get an incredible five
percent off that is incredible deal I
replaced my better skin with Emma Sleep
mattress if only we had that in USSR we
would have defeated the evilest
capitalist pig dogs insomnia destroyed
the Soviet Union you already get up to
50 off from Emma Sleep mattress plus an
extra five percent off when you use our
code and that's not all you also get
free shipping and returns up to 200
nights trial sleeps a 10-year warranty
with free shipping delivery and returns
and washable covers to boot you get all
of this when you use the link
www.ama
trigger for an additional five percent
off on top of whatever discount is on
the website so if there's deal for fifty
percent off trigonometry funds get 55
percent off I will never look at Yogi
berskin the generations of cases have
slept on in the same way again
I'm delighted to say that our brilliant
guest today is a psychoanalyst and a
Tavistock whistleblower Mark 7's welcome
to trigonometry thanks for having me
okay so I'm a psychoanalyst originally
trained as a psychiatric nurse worked in
Psychiatry for over 40 years
and for the last 20 of those in the NHS
I worked in the Tavistock as a senior
member of staff part of the management
and then uh I I retired from the NHS 18
months ago and I took up a post as a
governor which is a voluntary post on
the Tavistock Board of governance and I
reside there's um over one of the issues
that was being discussed at the time and
it has been embroiled in a well a
scandal is probably the one wrong word
to put it but it is a scandal of sorts
uh around uh the gender transitioning
change the transitioning of young
children did you dive into that and
explain to us what is happening at the
moment
yeah so if you can pitch uh the the sort
of history of the Tavistock is in
psychological work it's not in
medication or genetics that all goes on
at The Institute of Psychiatry and the
mordsly so this is the the sort of you
know it's psychotherapeutics looking
into the psychological functioning of
the Mind
but um about 20 years ago a service was
set up called jids which was an
experimental service is basically seeing
kids with gender dysphoric
and the thing that set it apart from the
rest of the trust was that there was a
sort of
recourse to sort of treating their
problems hormonally
um and this was a sort of experimental
and controversial treatment at the time
so in a way it sort of it moved away
from the tavistock's Traditions if you
like I I've been part of the man I was
part of the management for about 20
years I was called the head of Nursing
and then I I was in charge of the adult
and Adolescent department for about five
years
but my wife worked in in the jid service
in about 2005 and she went into the
surface because she was interested in
working at the Tavistock she got another
bit of the job was doing uh training
and she quickly came quite uncomfortable
with the fact that a lot of kids were
sort of they come very determined
they're very fixed in their view that
they're in the wrong uh gender and that
they they want to transition and they
want to be given pills to transition and
the tablet stop is the sort of
psychological gatekeeper so you go to
the Tavistock you've seen by the Sabbath
you assessed there and then you'll moved
on to UCL where the the hormones are
given
and my wife became very unhappy with
what was going on back then Marcus sorry
to interrupt it you keep interrupting
because I'll carry on no no but no it's
all great I just want to clarify for the
viewers and listeners when you say kids
how old are these children
well this this whole area has changed
exponentially so if we went back to the
first 30 years of my time in Psychiatry
there were small numbers of people that
would transitioned post 18
mainly male to female sort of 80 85
in the last 15 20 years there's been
this exponential rise and a completely
different cohort and these are 85 female
to male and they're getting younger and
younger so I think in her day there are
a lot of 15 14 15 16 year olds now
you're getting kids of 10 11 12. so the
age at which kids are wanting to
transition get is getting pushed lower
and the age at which people are prepared
to give hormones has got lower and lower
and you mentioned that your wife was
becoming increasingly unhappy at this
trend what was it that she was concerned
about
well basically our usual approach would
be to do a thorough psychological
investigation of what was going on with
the kid what's going on with the family
lots of these kids are on the autistic
spectrum they have all sorts of
secondary comorbid issues that they're
sort of um socially phobic they've got
Eating Disorders they may be depressed
and what she felt there should be a
thorough psychological investigation as
was the tavistock's tradition into
family Dynamics individual psychology
and she felt that there was too much of
a willingness to sort of go along with
the kid in terms of the kids idea
they've got there's one problem with one
solution and they basically want to get
through past the gay Gatekeepers onto
UCL
that's a generalized picture but it was
it was a sort of predominant
um picture that was being presented
so I'd say I was a part of the Senior
Management I said well what we would
usually do it's very multi-disciplinary
it's not like a traditionally medically
hierarchical
service you've got
um lots of different disciplines and
you're used to sort of discussing and
debating approaches and I said well
you've got to go back and and challenge
the culture and she felt she was quite a
senior person by the time she'd arrived
in this service this was was not welcome
it was a sort of shutting down of any
dissent or wish to examine what was
going on beneath the service for the kid
etc etc and she felt she got nowhere it
rapidly became apparent there was a
politicization of this whole area so
again unusually
there was a very close relationship with
mermaids and
um with gender intelligence the the uh
the track Charities and they had an
unusual sort of influence over the sort
of culture
um now I when I was in charge of the
adult and Adolescent Department I would
have relationships of mind and some of
the Charities but they but they wouldn't
sort of insist on the culture or look
ask me to run them by the protocols for
treatment etc etc but there's been a
sort of enormous policy capture into
this area where you've got the
affirmation model which was adopted with
virtually no evidence and jettison in
um what used to be in place was what's
called watchful waiting which is that
gender dysphoric kids you know most of
them will desist if supported and left
of their own devices
um so there's a sort of huge capture of
of the clinical environment I think that
once you're sort of um your decision
making is based on a sort of belief a
pre-existing belief structure may be
embedded within the clinicians may be
met by the parents at some of the
parents and some of the kids you you're
not in a clinical environment you see
lots of people you know will come into
Psychiatry and they when people are in a
sort of chaotic
state of mind and they feel that their
minds are falling apart they often Focus
down narrowly on there's one problem
with one solution
now psychological health is usually
based on the opposite it's based on sort
of opening things out thinking that
we're complicated we've got many
different moving Parts as a personality
and that usually our problems are made
up of all sorts of things coming
together so we're trying to sort of open
things out for index for the kids for
example you're saying okay that's what
you believe let's have a look at what's
who you are what's going on beneath the
surface what might be troubling you
let's open this dialogue out so we think
about things in the round
um and you you're you're not going along
with
um fixed beliefs there's one problem and
one solution
so there's one more thing is so one
thing that's often
um talks about is that the kids
completely certain
well for me that's a red flag you know
that if you're making very serious
decisions you would expect to have
doubts questions anxieties conflicts the
absence of those is a problem
you know and we believe and and we know
a psychoanalysts you know that beliefs
can be driven by all sorts of forces not
all of them healthy or rational you know
so a person comes to me and says I'm
absolutely sure I'm EX
and my job isn't to butt heads with them
but it is to say well hang on I wonder
why you you're so fixated on this belief
and why you have to drum that into me
that I can't challenge it because there
are tyrannical states of mind again a
psychoanalyst you're sort of wary of you
sort of think well hang on a minute
what's driving this and why can't you
why can't we examine this area because
you know most most of the time we know
that sort of when we're in a healthy
State you know you're not so defensive
you can have things examined and looked
at from different points of view but
when you become fanatical it's usually
being driven by something else and
that's my job as a cycle analysis try
and understand what that is
what happened was when I took up this
voluntary position as governor two
things landed on the governor's desk and
it was a governor my job was to sort of
oversee is the trust doing what it's
supposed to be doing
um we're not part of management we're
just a sort of Watchdog if you like and
two things came on the desk one was a
letter written by ten parents whose kids
are being treated by jids
basically what they said it was a very
detailed letter saying we had hoped our
kids all got comality problems we'd hope
it'd be a thorough psychological
investigation Etc et cetera that didn't
happen we're we're not happy we feel
like that our kids have been fast
tracked through to the medication so
that was one thing
then a colleague of mine Dave Bell is
probably the best known clinician in the
Tavistock
who was the staff Governor previously
previous
um and we didn't overlap I I started as
Governor he'd left
and basically he'd been approached by 10
members of staff from jids with very
similar concerns to the parents so he'd
done a report the trust knew about it
and then the report was presented to the
trust board I think that's right I think
that's right and of course it was saying
a lot of similar things staff felt the
relationship with mermaids was too close
a lot of these kids that were being
transitioned had got secondary and so
quite comorbid problems
um that there wasn't enough interest in
sort of debates and discussion within
the culture of the service etc etc
what the trusted was a very unhappy
about the report they wouldn't let me
see the report if I in Spotify I said
look I want to see this report if I'm
going to adjudicate whether the trust is
doing his job I've got to see all the
materials
that was withheld so I thought that's
odd why would you withhold that report
from a governor and there are other
Governors that requested it as well
the second thing with that was oh that's
right so then they set up
um the medical director was going to do
the trust report
so several of us said that's fine
but we'd like Dave Bell to be at the
final hearing of the report so he can
hear whether the medical director's
report is addressing the concerns
raising by the staff
no he can't
so I sort of I don't know
um
there was quite a few emails went
backwards and forwards over a sort of
six month period contesting this and and
it was contested when we met
and it appeared to me that the trust
wanted to use the medical director's
report to bury the concerns about the
service
and and I could see then the extent to
which the trust and its management this
service was politicized
it's quite extraordinary what's going on
and sometimes when you when you talk to
people they go it can't be as bad as you
say it is you must be I don't know
you've lost the plot you've hit a
midlife crisis you're angry with a
tavista no it really is quite
extraordinary it you know as a mental
health practitioner someone who's proud
to be in the business that I'm in I'm
really quite ashamed by you know the
lack of it this is
political belief and ideology over
rational scientific argument
our brilliant and returning guest needs
very little introduction Nigel farage
welcome back to trigonometry it's good
to be here and not doing it via bloom in
Zoom I couldn't agree with you more it's
a real pleasure
on the fuel bill
side of things which is just I still
don't think people understand what's
about to happen
I really don't think they understand the
first week of April when those bills hit
the mat
for their q1 gas and electricity bills
there's going to be absolute shock and
outrage number one massive mistake the
conservatives adopted price caps can you
believe it
can you believe that a conservative
government I mean why not set a price
for a loaf of bread
I miss what the marxists did
you know nuts policy it never works it's
nearly always counterproductive
but it leads to a much bigger question
Net Zero is in economic terms
I think the most self-destructive policy
that has ever been put forward by a
British government in the history of the
nation
that doesn't mean
that I'm against finding ways of
producing energy that emit less CO2 and
cause less environmental damage but I'm
a pragmatist you know we still burn four
and a half million tons of coal a year
in this country we have to to make steel
do you know what we imported all
we're importing 50 of our Natural Gas
when we've got vast reserves possibly as
much as a trillion
pounds worth of natural gas in
Lancashire and Cambria alone hey that's
half the national debt it's quite
interesting when you look at something a
lot of jobs too tens of thousands of
well-paid jobs and if you're gonna if
you're going to use the blooming stuff
anyway you might as well make it here
the Americans
rethought their energy policy you know
five six years ago
and the price of natural gas in America
is half the price that it is here
we then have walked onto people's bills
incredibly
25 of your electricity was green
subsidies money that goes to rich land
owners money that goes to large foreign
companies building wind farms we've put
so much faith in wind energy or if truth
be told so much money has been made out
of wind energy by those in the elites
that we leave ourselves vulnerable at
some point of a not too distant future
to blackouts so yes commodity prices
globally have gone up but we've left
ourselves absolutely exposed not just to
World Markets but left ourselves exposed
you know nine percent of our electricity
comes from France through an
interconnector you know so I think we
should be self-sufficient in energy we
should be aiming uh with areas like gas
to get people's bills down I don't think
a penny peace
should go to massive Global Industries
in the form of green subsidy
um so I think this
I've Got a Feeling actually that the
energy debate and the Net Zero debate is
going to be huge and Boris stands up and
says isn't it marvelous we've we've cut
our CO2 output by 44 since 1990. well if
you close down nearly all of your
chemical plants your aluminum smelters
your refiners and you move steel plants
from red car to India and then and then
import the products back you yourself
may be producing less CO2 but globally
the net games is even more co2s being
produced so I think we've got this
hopelessly
catastrophically wrong and
I think it's a function of and by the
way labor are just as bad on this if not
worse
and I think it's a function of career
politicians a function of people living
inside Metropolitan bubbles in London
um pray to the lobbying influences of
some people who are rather good at this
and utterly disconnected from The Real
World and it's about to blow up this
year it's about a blower
foreign
[Music]
[Music]